in case you've been living in a cave the
last year
covered 19 is still going pretty strong
in 2021
unfortunately we still cannot travel
anywhere around the world
yes in australia we're a lot luckier
than most countries
but we can't really go too far
now the first i'm able to travel is from
my comfy spot
to the foreign side of the couch which
as i'm about to demonstrate
isn't very far at all
as an architect that can't travel but
absolutely loves to travel
i had to get creative about this
situation
what's going on guys my name is david
thomage and welcome back to the channel
today we're talking about how you as an
architect
can hack your way through traveling
during a global pandemic
it sounds pretty crazy but we have the
skills to be able to do some amazing
things
so i thought why not actually utilize it
this all actually came about
from a video call with a mate of mine
over in america
his company actually manufactures all
the t-shirts i own
genuinely i have about 20 of them and
can guarantee
they are the best shirts in the game
there's a link down below if you want to
check it out
i get nothing from it it's just
genuinely me showing my love to the
company
back to the main point i guess we were
really discussing covert 19
travel and all things social media and
it really got me thinking
how can i utilize my skills as an
architect
to create some amazing social media
content for everything that i do
on the side well i thought it's a very
very simple answer
and as long as my imagination can run
wild anything can be done
so this isn't going to be a tutorial
video i'm kind of hoping you understand
what i'm talking about here
if you are an architect an architect
student or anything of the sort you
probably have the skills and the
know-how
to replicate what i'm about to tell you
so make sure you pay attention to these
steps so you can create some incredible
travel photos without actually having to
leave your room so the process obviously
started for me on archicad
where i was able to model that office
scene it was a very simple scene
it was one room and it was designed in
such a way to be able to create those
long vertical instagram shots after i
finished in archicad i took it over to
twin motion
which as you guys probably aware of is
my rendering platform of choice at the
moment
i'm looking to move over to the unreal
engine suite but i haven't got around to
it yet there's a few things on my
priority list
twin motion is pretty good but i do like
to enhance it
with the materials and furniture from cg
access i did make a video on this before
it was called
render like a pro i'll try link it above
if i remember if i don't just
search render like a pro david thomas
and i'm sure it would have come up on
youtube
they have some great materials it's not
sponsored i know it sounds sponsored
but they do have some great materials
and some great furniture that you can
link in as fbx files
and make these scenes look a lot more
realistic
so that's how i took it from your
standard twin motion to the final
product that you see
so when it came time to export the final
renders i actually exported
two versions of the final product one
of just the scene and a second of the
scene with an npc
or a non-player character imported into
that scene
this allowed me to understand scale size
and proportions
later on when i needed to photoshop
myself into
the process now there is a way that i've
actually figured out that you can create
a
3d replica of yourself and actually
import yourself
into twin motion or unreal engine i'm
having a bit of a play with it now and
hopefully i'll be able to give a
tutorial
to you guys a little bit later on if
that's something you're interested in
smash that subscribe button and i'll
definitely
bring you that content soon after those
images were exported i had to ask my
fiance to take some photos of me
sitting outside on a chair just randomly
in the middle of the lounge room it was
a still image that i was able to take
and then
photoshop and cut me out to be able to
put me in an image
as i'm sure you guys have done this
millions and millions of times
during university or even if you're
still at university you probably do this
all the time on photoshop
so it's a very simple quick easy
procedure once those photos were taken
obviously i brought them back onto the
computer and started editing them on
lightroom i tried to adjust the
parameters and adjust the lighting
situation
to match the native scene of the twin
motion
export the twin motion export was kind
of dark and moody but still had a warmer
vibe to it because of the fire
so i try to color match that before i
brought that image across
to the twin motion render export once it
was there i opened and overlaid
both images in photoshop as well as that
npc
render so i could actually understand
the scale and size of how big
i was meant to be in that scene once
that was all set up it was pretty easy
you just
shifted yourself scaled yourself plonked
yourself in
and obviously added a few shadows here
and there now because obviously this
isn't extra enough i had to take it
out of photoshop back into lightroom and
drop in one of my custom presets that
i'm thinking about manufacturing for you
guys and producing
to be able to give you some great
quality renders at the end of the day so
they're not just your stock standard
twin motion exports
but i'm not really decided on that so
maybe leave a comment down below
let me know if you'd like some presets
for your exports to make them look that
extra bit crispy and yeah after that
preset was added
bam that photo was complete and it was
magical
it genuinely looked like i was in the
scene overlooking the ski
fields and having the time of my life so
you see
without ever having to actually leave my
home i was able to travel to the south
of france where i was originally meant
to be at this time
pouring myself a nice glass of wine and
overlooking the ski fields
without actually ever leaving my kitchen
my dining room or even my office
actually i'm going to leave this here
because i don't actually drink any wine
little fun fact